[Music]
you spread that the wreckage from the
worst disaster in the history of the US
Navy was located the USS Indianapolis
was sunk by Japanese torpedoes in the
final days of World War two shortly
after completing a critical mission of
the nearly twelve hundred sailors and
Marines on board just 317 survived too
late today less than two dozen of those
men are still alive and for many of them
the discovery of the Indianapolis in the
Philippine Sea is the closing chapter in
their war story Don Dahler reports yes
much easier today than it is delay of
Edgar Harrell was an eighteen-year-old
marine when on July 30th 1945 the events
that would shape his life unfolded in an
instant a few minutes after midnight two
Japanese torpedoes slammed into the hull
of the Indianapolis the heavy cruiser
sank in 12 minutes and no distress
signal was sent the crew had just
delivered parts of the atomic bomb to
Tinian Island and was traveling uh Ness
courted no one was coming to help for
the estimated 900 men who survived the
blast an even more terrifying fate lay
ahead
the survivors spent the next four days
in the open water
battling blistering Sun dehydration
hypothermia and warding off constant
attacks from swarms of sharks a shark
would be coming through the group and he
would take someone fairly close to you
take you take him under 72 years later
and 18,000 feet below the ocean surface
the iron hull of the Indianapolis has
been discovered that's it we've got it
an underwater expedition spearheaded by
billionaire Microsoft co-founder Paul
Allen located the ship last weekend for
the first time you can point at a place
on the globe and say here's where this
ship is we can now memorialize it Doug
Stanton spent years interviewing the
crew of the Indianapolis for his book in
harm's way he says many of the survivors
share a common trait at some point they
had been pushed to such a bring such a
precipice that this experience of
floating in this void of an ocean was a
crucible and they were
really being asked like Who am I the
story of the Indianapolis has inspired
movies television shows and books lost
100 men I don't know how many sharks
maybe thousand Robert Shaw's character
in Jaws delivers a chilling monologue
about the terrors the survivors faced
nothing about a shaggy
and the film's popularity may have
helped some of the survivors begin to
heal that's one of the first ways that
they really dealt with their own
feelings about this experience and also
you know that movie is important because
it's the first time Indianapolis moves
into the American consciousness for the
men of the Indianapolis the ordeal of
July and August 1945 never drifted far
from their consciousness but the
discovery of the ship and final resting
place for so many of their shipmates may
provide the closure they've sought
throughout the decades it still leaves
open the trauma of that experience but
the fact that we found the ship now that
brings closure to the story of the end
Annapolis for CBS this morning Saturday
Don Dahler New York so glad some of
those veterans are still around to see
that they found this ship yeah and in
saying that the trauma will continue but
at least you've got that closing chapter
to one part of the story
our producer Bryan Applegate told me a
mayor he said that book in harm's way
which he read one of the scariest books
he's ever he's ever read which is a good
endorsement right there I will be
downloading